-Guys, finally, it is Tuesday.
it is time for "WeTweet"!
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets.
We're all going to vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You see them there.
You can vote for all of them,
if you like.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
We're going to see
the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers?
-Got it.
-Alright. Very good.
Whichever gets the most likes,
we're gonna tweet it out,
so you can all like it
and wetweet it.
[ Laughs ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright, guys,
you ready for this?
-[ Cheers ]
-Alright.
And be kind. It's the holidays.
Okay, here we go.
The first tweet is...
-Wow.
-Yeah, just dead silence.
[ Laughter ]
Not even a titter.
-Not even a titter.
-Not even a titter for Twitter.
-Not even a golf applause.
-Nothing on that one. Alright.
I think the votes are
probably in on this one.
Let's see the results.
Yeah.
-Whoa!
[ Sad tuba ]
Wow! 132.
-Not everyone even voted on
that.
-No. They said, "We're good.
No thanks."
-"Jimmy, we're here for
the commercial breaks."
[ Laughter ]
-Want more Terry's Steaks.
-This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
It's all -- Every page.
Some weird -- Yeah.
-Neon blue.
-Smurf.
-Windex.
-Yeah, Windex.
Smurf, whatever they want.
Yeah, here we go.
Let's see the results
on this one.
I think this one
will fare better.
Alright. Not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-112.
-Yeah.
-Tough crowd. Very honest.
Very honest.
It doesn't really matter,
I should also let you know.
[ Laughter ]
This next one here says...
-Come on.
-I don't want to go there.
It's too much work.
-How is Jim?
-Oh, he's doing well.
Let's see the results here.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I knew that.
I appreciate that.
So they do work.
The clickers do work.
Alright, that's real.
I love this. Alright. Fun.
This is good.
That might be --
-That might be the winner, 171.
-I think it definitely is
going to be the winner.
Alright, let's see.
The next one says...
[ Laughter ]
Would you like a black one?
-Please.
Do you have a blue one?
-We don't have black markers.
-What do you have?
-We have blue.
-I'm good.
-Okay.
Let's see the results
on this one.
Yeah. Wow.
[ Crowd booing ]
-[ Sad tuba ]
-No, you can't boo. No, stop.
Don't play that. Don't boo.
They're all fun.
-Well, that tweet was
the Pepsi of this round.
-Yeah.
-Wow!
-Alright. This last one says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow!
-This is just
my favorite sweater.
How dare you?
Alright, here we go.
Let's see the results.
-Oh!
-That's the winner right there,
everybody.
By one vote.
Ugly Christmas sweater.
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a wetweet, and enjoy.